[Music]
when logo comes up it's very suggestive
believe me and put it up and get it
again watch brave I know right when it's
dark
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
by the people yeah you thought it was
worth stopping the show - sure
absolutely tonight after a few drinks
I'd like to know how you got that right
angle
boating it you can take that away now
boating accident all right here we go
here are some BuzzFeed remember the
premise forty minutes ago BuzzFeed's
running a little dry running out of
ideas here's some lists I've seen
recently check it out look at this one
nine famous astronomers who started out
as peeping toms yeah there's 12 babies
who believe in smaller government that's
7 Matadors who work from home let's just
down 41 camel toes that kind of look
like crotches with you 17 babysitter's
guaranteed to break up your family oh
dear
15 people who weren't famous to begin
with and are unrecognizable today teen
transgender Forks transitioning into
spoons
I like this one thirteen endangered
species that we're kind of asking for it
I hate the fork-tailed badger yeah look
at this one three guys named Josh who
decided not to pursue a career in comedy
that made the writers lab only the right
all the Josh's yeah sixteen jeopardy
champions dying alone they won one
answer he didn't know what is love Wow
you love the meanest ones silence I have
a rotten heart yeah look at this one
221 SNL cast members you just don't
remember
I remember rainbow chibi separates look
at this eight signs you might be on fire
here's 118 balls of pizza dough that
kind of looked like Marilyn Manson
without makeup and finally 11 police
chalk outlines you'd like to bang
[Applause]
good shape
you